I would go to jail in Pakistan just a
few months after 9/11 this just in you
are looking at obviously a very
disturbing live shot there that is the
World Trade Center and we have
unconfirmed reports this morning that a
plane has crashed into one of the towers
and me being the only American there
wasn't easy
someone put a five thousand rupee bounty
on my head people will try to collect
all the time I was in more fights than I
can count
I've been stabbed someone firebombed
myself hi my name is Erica day I'm a
poker player producer actor stunt
coordinator and stunt man my life is a
little different than most I'm the
youngest of six boys yet all my brothers
consider me their big brother when I was
in third grade I was run over by a
school bus I was told that I wouldn't
make it through the night then I was
given a very small chance of making it
through the week my pelvis was shattered
like a glass jar I've had over 50
surgeries from the age of eight to the
age of 15 when I was 12 I did my first
movie I was an extra and I'm movie with
Christina Applegate called across the
moon I knew I wanted to be in Hollywood
I knew I wanted to be in the
entertainment industry soon as I turned
18 I knew I wanted to get Ali Antelope
Valley and I moved to LA as soon as I
could I lived in this place
called Eagle Rock and even though I was
working as an actor I was getting small
parts on Nickelodeon shows CW shows work
wasn't full-time for me so I had to pick
up jobs side jobs and one of my side
jobs is working as a personal trainer at
the world gym in Burbank well one of my
clients was a very successful Armenian
businessman would hire young people to
travel around the world for him
importing expensive leather goods and
he'd pay them for it I knew this guy for
a while before I would finally agree to
take a trip for him and it would be one
of these trips right after 9/11 that I
would find out that I was really being
used to smuggle narcotics a few months
after 9/11 happened
no one wanted to make trips
understandably and the trip that would
end up sending me to jail wasn't even
supposed to be my trip it was supposed
to be one of my older brothers trips and
he backed out when he found out it was
to Pakistan normally the trips would be
to Turkey I I always say I'm glad it was
me that had happened - I know I'm glad
it was me that it would have happened -
because I I know I don't think my
brother would have been able to get
through it I would go to jail in
Pakistan just a few months after 9/11 I
would be the only American in a prison
meant to house only 1800 but it was
overcrowded there were over 6,000
prisoners there hundreds coming and
going every day and me being the only
American there wasn't easy the first
nine and a half months that I was in
jail I spent on death row and the reason
I was on death row is because the bounty
that somebody had put on my head and
people kept trying to collect it the
superintendent at the time figured that
was the safest place for me so while on
death row I met some prisoners who were
there for mostly murder one of the
prisoners I would meet those and he was
there for for killing 11 of his wives
family members him and his wife fell in
love without their family's consent and
they had to go into hiding while they
were in hiding their families were
feuding with each other they were
blaming each other for hiding the other
and they were killing each other
what broad murad out of hiding was his
mother and sister were gang raped by his
wives family members and killed by let
having their breasts cut off and
bleeding to death
so Murad set up an ambush and killed 11
of his wives family members on death row
Murad was very kind to me now one day I
get called early in the afternoon and
Murad had planned this whole meal for us
he had chicken he had Pepsi he had sweet
dishes everything wasn't spicy in
Pakistan they love spicy food I
personally have always not like spicy
food
I asked Marah what's the occasion he
said no occasion just hanging out he
would have had to have bribed a lot of
guards to get this kind of milling to
Joe hung out in his cell all day that
day and when I went back - it was called
back to my two cell
I said hey Murat I'll see you next week
he said inshallah and he ended up being
hung the next day he shared his last
meal with me
he had it prepared so that I'd enjoyed
it not him and he didn't tell me after
six months I had a DEA agent come to the
prison and talk to me about the man that
set me up up until this point they
hadn't been able to find him they
couldn't find him because of the name
and the only reason they they were able
to find him was because six months after
I was arrested a Swedish woman working
for him doing the same thing I was doing
which was importing expensive leather
goods and beating the import tax by
claiming it as their own she was
arrested she lost her luggage at JFK
Airport but she continued on our on her
itinerary to LAX
they found professionally sewn into the
walls of her suitcase narcotics
basically what happened to me and when
he told me that story about the Swedish
girl I felt relieved I figured okay now
that you guys got the real drug smuggler
what are you gonna do to help me get out
of here
and he says that if this was happening
in America you'd be going home tonight
but because it's here in Pakistan you
still have to go through the legal
system eleven and a half months goes by
and I've been going back in court back
and forth the court it's so many times
sometimes the judge wouldn't show up
most of the time the other lawyer
wouldn't show up or my own lawyer want
to show up or the witnesses when it show
up the embassy figured okay well Eric's
innocent so this is what we're gonna do
to help him out it somehow talked to the
judge the judge was going to give me a
two-year prison sentence and with time
time and good behavior and some
remissions I was only gonna spend about
one year two months in jail but here was
the catch I would have to plead guilty
for a crime I didn't commit now I
thought about this I had some time to
think about it and I didn't want to
plead guilty for a crime I didn't commit
I had already been made fun of I'd had
my life strips for me
and I knew that if I pled guilty for a
crime I didn't commit it would eat at me
the interpreter for the embassy a guy
named also who came with the consular
usually he says to me Eric what's worth
more of you your pride or your freedom
that made my decision very easy for me
because my pride is worth a hell of a
lot more to me than my freedom I refused
to plead guilty knowing that I was
facing life or death the judge gave me
seven years but seven years I could do
seven years I was I was mentally
prepared for so I was happy I was I
became friends with a lot of different
people I became friends with the future
Prime Minister of Pakistan I became
friends with the the hijackers from the
PanAm hijacking of 86 the people that
were responsible for 23 deaths in prison
go in jail if you can't really pick your
friends you're just grateful for having
them because we were foreigners that's
what we had to we had to bond because of
that it's weird it's really just you
against the Pakistanis but the
Palestinians those guys would become my
brothers in jail they would end up
saving my life more times than one when
riots would happen they would stand
side-by-side with me and they would
fight I had a knife in my stomach and
one of my shoulder because there was a
hit on me and it was the hijackers that
helped to keep anyone else off of me so
at least the fight was more fair it
would also get me a lawyer
I would help represent my case and get
me out of jail December 16th comes
around and I'm presented in front of the
courts and I tell the judges using all
the lower court's points against them
I'm able to convince the judges that I'm
innocent and the judges say to me they
they believe that I'm innocent but they
can't say they kept a American in jail
for three years for a crime he didn't
commit it makes them look bad so they
said they would have to decide on the
16th I find out they decided to give me
time served which is fine
I never pled guilty and I got to leave
that prison with my head high I know how
bad it can be and my whole life has
never been a cakewalk it's it's never
been a picnic everything's amazing
everything the little things you gonna
miss when they're all gone no if you go
to jail tomorrow you don't know when
you're gonna get out I guarantee you're
gonna miss being able to say hello to
someone that you thought would always be
there you're gonna miss being able to
watch a sunset
you're gonna miss being able to go to
the beach and just feel the ocean on
your feet
you're gonna miss being able to grab a
taco or a hot dog or you're gonna miss
being able to go and watch a matinee
you're gonna miss being able to pet a
dog all that stuff is what you're gonna
miss you're not going to miss your money
you're not gonna miss your job you're
not gonna miss what car you have or how
big your house is you're gonna miss the
little freedoms that you've always taken
advantage of
[Music]
you